bonjour et bienvenue dans ce débat la
télé spécial rondes de numéros scène de
50 en 2015 championnat de france
nationale donc avec le grand maître
international mathieu cornette salué
matthieu bonduelle
alors content aujourd'hui voilà je suis
dans un état assez second ces jeux 5h30
j'étais à mon avis à + 3 au bout de 2h
heure et demie de jeu et j'ai dû payer
deux fois la partie je me sens juste
fatigué mais je suis content et bien sûr
content on a gagné une partie et ça m'a
pas un buteur cette semaine un très bon
début de championnat pour toi parce que
tu sonné dans la solide j'ai eu trois
fois les nord quatre premières rondes
dont etienne bacrot boys au lit et égard
amiens mais bon j'ai un petit regret de
la partie numéro un contre de shekels
chef là en numéro 2 j'étais quand même
beaucoup mieux dans l'ouverture mais par
contre j'ai pas tendre gaza parce
qu'après je suis un autre futur
d'entzheim nov ça m'a encore comme
aujourd'hui ça me laissait échapper
c'était même pire parce que je me suis
retrouvé moins bien et après il y est
hier pendant que j'ai eu un peu de
chance et a joué une partie tendue avec
cette notion une préparation
j'ai décidé de réagir de façon dynamique
mais j'ai tellement bien mais après j'ai
réussi à s'accaparer une pièce mon âme à
la fin on m'a dit qu'ils ne pouvaient
aussi de polliat mais bon j'étais
tellement content de m'en être sorti
alors on va voir je vous dis ta partie
qui est question de contrôle christian
bauer et la gelée
je la connais très bien je n'ai jamais
battu alors on va déjà obligé perdu très
souvent je vais juste mettre ton nom
donc ici tu avais les blancs vont mano
christian bauer à lévis les noirs up
petite manip est c'est fait ça c'est
clair j'ai décidé de me christian jeu
tout comme jeu tout le temps ils
changent à chaque partie j'ai joué à 415
mo 4 trop tu as l'habitude de jouer le
jeu changent mais le 4 en ce moment je
le jure un peu plus et en plus contre
lui ça me plaisait un peu plus mais là
il a réfléchi cinq minutes censé
commencer la dernière fois je les gens
martinique mais je des cinq ici l'âge de
6 ans il a écrit un livre sur ben si
c'est sûr déçu ce oui donc milliards de
60 normal donc là le jeu c'est sympa il
a joué six pays celle ci sera sa mission
spéciale de la fille d'henri la joue
plus trop
plus de 30 secondes bon ok bon je
m'attendais à carreaux cassés 515 points
ouais ok c'est ici que j'ai vu qu'il
avait je sois récemment à merveille il a
deux parties dans la maison que j'avais
regardé 5 minutes mais j'avais regardé
une heure deux mille fois j'ai regardé
pendant quatre heures sans me le
rappeler n'a rien mais j'ai fait un peu
un bluff
ok j'ai soulevé cinq j'ai vu qu'il a
déjà 2,6 récemment donc ça c'est une
anti façon il reçoit nîmes au pouvoir
moi qui jouais avec les noirs on le joue
tout le temps fondées sur wii donc tu as
l'habitude apprécié ce que je joue aussi
avec son rock petit rock qui avait lieu
fait de la matanie calais c'est ce qui
fait qu'il ya plus jamais de fournir les
reprendre en douze mois
et là en fait j'ai joué un coup qui
existe quasiment pas il ya deux parties
à mon niveau
oui dobbin de gamme ce qui compte une
voiture verte c'est d'habitude ici vous
tous il accueille des 4 à 6 oui
donc en fait récemment le cou à la mode
c'est genre des 4 et après on met le
font eux deux et on joue au fc 4 où joue
avec une sorte de ghetto ah oui on va
mettre les taux de marty on a trop vite
tu vas trop vite le recteur mais n'a
plus qu'à la mode qui ont été capturés
durant on prend les cavaliers on est
gros mais frau et de et où je sais 4
passes et d'avoir un sang neuf est en
train eto'o ou call c4 qui empêche
dessine ici sont joue ses cartes tout de
suite le problème c'est que le foot
façon qu'il est stupide
oui et donc les noirs ont pas joué à six
ils vont jouer les caïds et qu'à tout
même j'essaie d'apporter donc là mon
idée je suis qu'il est stupide tu veux
dire parce qu'il y avait toutes ces
cases il est bloqué en chemises rouges
les jaunes cours très rares jeux x 4 wii
qui était intéressant parce que tu le
saurons peut-être lui aussi de sa
publication à cette question c'est qui
connaît pas en fait l'idée bon ça donne
pas davantage pour les blondes mais
c'est intéressant de l'idée c'est que
s'ils jouent qu'avec g6 où j'ai six
cavaliers g6 ici je peux jouer cette
fois c'est 3 je change de plan en fait
et le phénomène normalement quand on
joue avec ses 3 les noirs jouent avec à
6b 5 buts
oui mais là si je vous ai trois ya plus
de 5 donc c'est ça l'idée bon dessin que
si possible on est déjà à six qui le
coup cannes ou de loin le plus logique
donc maintenant je sais qu'un gymnase
gagné fou d'emma nasa green fund est
certain qu'ils poussent enfin ça c'est
donc qu'elle s'est cassé car du coup la
différence et par mme lacasse b6 pardon
si je sais qu'à directement mon fou pour
aller en c2 oui d'où il est quand même
mieux bien et la case b6 est affaiblie
par exemple à la 6 x 4 c'est mieux pour
les bourgs mais bon après la position et
au quai paul les images où est la ligne
la plus logique les jeux kg 6 kg 6 t4
alors maintenant on fait ça tombait
plutôt bien de société la partie je me
répète je me prendrais quand tu
comprends dans notre lait prend des
quinquas va les prendre la voiture
ressemble maintenant toutes les pièces
quand même
on de l'air on voit que dont je termine
mon idée si c'est un mode de jeu vous
faut 3 pendant ont évité deux fois trois
ans explique ce que je veux c'est sain
c'est maintenant que les cases noires
sont faibles si je prends en existe et
c'est simple c'est simple tout de suite
j'ai contrôle des six décennies tournée
donc là je connais si la jeune homme
sait c'est qu'elle augmenterait logique
oui la belle qui envisage de le penser
car on vit c'est cavada mais toujours en
général la sicilienne en plus tout le
monde bien passé surtout avec la 6
assists ont surtout avec le statisme
parce qu'on est les cases noires et je
fous des points donc que [ __ ] les
trois vont le 31.3 il est le fou des six
qui est le jeu me rappelait quand
j'avais préparé seul le chevreuil dans
la partie principale il avait prouvé en
d4 plus fous des six mais ça transpose
je me rappelle que j'avais mis ça
transposons donc là ils attaquent h 12
je sais même pas s'il a pu appréhender
cap d'abord en plein doute
on va dire j'ai trois maintenant ça je
sais que ça change rien ça fait mal et
sa transposition des quatre maintenant
qu'elle va les prendre dans prendre des
quatre maintenant de dame prend attaque
j'ai sept mois là non parce qu'il ya
face à simon un peu m avec un peu je
peux en faudrait 5 et l'écologie
cashman à 16,5 et d'être mieux tout de
suite oui c'est simple à prendre g7 à ce
que la case des six jours c'est bébé
nommé le fossé vu sortir à jamais il
vous suit donc d'en sortir la frisure
show est normal web et ce alors ça non
seulement ça couvre bien plus ces
attaques des deux dames d2 obligés d'en
france et 4 en fait si les noms je trade
un contre et ils ont juste rien
voilà j'ai que un c'est le coût qui est
assez étonnant passage c'est faux c'est
2 donc là tu as donné un fou un pirate
ou alors c'était ma préparation mon
compte il accepte encore la partie est
donc faussé de ses obligés parce que le
foot n'a pas de bonnes cases sur four b3
les dames point qu'à son public ah oui
et donc est faussée de la pointe que tu
protèges de cas mais il ya le problème
de fond mais s'il faut prendre les deux
il ya faute est trop hop sous des droits
et le fou la dame est attaqué et à
défendre et à lapins moyenne des formes
de fou a là aucune case pour défendre le
fou en bessin quelques pas bégueule adam
et puis voilà c'est donc elle peut même
pas attaquer le foot est roi mais un
service gagnant s'appelle c'est pour une
question de respect pour éviter de
fausser 2 donc les la jeune dame c'est
celle dont je me rappelle c'est lé coût
qui avait été joueur je sais
ok mon avis l'idée sursis joue petit
rock à la pièce de dame s'est quelque
peu son jeu et on regarde tout ce que je
fous d'être offre maintenant le premier
deuil l'attaqué donc maintenant évident
tu reviens une fois que le cas très
protégé ici non car on est là donc je me
rappelle que le procès gb2 la
préparation c'était petit rock pour ses
seins
bref cas très bon c'est compliqué je me
rappelais pas de tour des détails mais
je savais qu'il ya des compensations la
partie dont les visas effet nul assez
rapidement mettez j'avais trouvé ça
intéressant un jeu pour une partie donc
les mots je décide donc là j'ai commencé
à réfléchir pour moi même des six
bon j'ai deux fois supérieur je sais pas
dans quel ordre les jouer double jeu
taurin d'abord tour c'est un gagneur
d'un gain de temps sur la colonne sur la
dalle mon idée c'est qu'elle il n'a pas
de bonnes cases et parce qu'il peut pas
les imbéciles fou faut pas lasser henk
van damme est donc d'aller enlever 8
vous des 8es en fait mon idée c'est que
je veux mettre un point b 6 quand j'ai
un fond des tiroirs 37 et du coup il
bouge pas du coup là le d'amd vite
qu'ils étaient à mon avis le bon coup et
pour éviter tout b6 exactement il est
complètement glisser les ggf quatre
membres de l'espace alors ça prend
l'espace on dit souvent aussi quelques 4
c'est mon goût que ça fait toujours un
moment là j'étais content d'accord fo lc
7 6 et ici hockey ici j'ai le shom et en
fait je pensais que lui voulait jouer
avec bessin s'il arrive à je devais
saint caprais même après rendre un pion
mouais on peut s'en sortir dans mon idée
c'est bien mais deux c'est ça j'ai
réfléchi longtemps que j'attends ça avec
ses gadgets à c'est la même idée
exactement je vais je fous b6 et je veut
l'empêcher de sortir son fils habite en
d6 le fou nous sommes en ça va bloquer
ses pions j'ai du coup sauf provisoire
dépend la dame est attaqué et puis la
tour pénétrer dans ces séries répond
donc là il a joué petit rock où ils
pourraient jouer bcp terme et 6 et b5
v6 dano sa puissance quand même si c'est
pareil
et j'ai grossi
il suffisait de pas que c'était possible
mais je pensais qu'il vient on à petit
roeulx qu'il a joué notre côté rock sous
les 6 layton ceci dit c'est vrai qu'il
est bloqué là mais
pourra sortir du port tuant 17 comme l'a
par exemple il a joué le coup que
j'attendais qu'ils donnent de 826 on
vend le stade français que j'ai toujours
de gain de temps donc va me lutz et bien
joué alors attends on va voir ça
pourquoi pourquoi situés dans ces cinq
ans je gagne autant sur la table à la
tour annoncé cette j'attaque la dame à 8
tu peux pas l'attaquer et donc du coût
de ce trailer de se développer je le
cavalier à 3 je sais pas s'ils signent
un coût mais avec mon idée c'est que
maintenant je vous auquel ces quatre
qu'elle gère 300 soit décelée gain de
temps surtout si c'est déjà aussi
puisqu'une au clair il est le dessin qui
donc là c'est typique j'ai quarante
minutes d'assistance à la pendule
il en a marre de sa position il veut
simplement couvrir la politique irakien
l'éruption il encore plus il faut pas
oublier voilà c'est a promis qu il a
pris un pilon est ce que c'est fatal en
général ouverture canton on prend comme
ça c'est parce que l'adversaire veut se
développer rapidement un sas annoncé
j'ai des chances de développement t il
je pense qu'il faut je le mange moi je
pense que des 5 c'est bien jeune mais
jouit en bien sûr si on prend qui on
prend et on se dit le fou est pas mal
parce qu'il peut plus bouger
musicalement je tiens juste à beaucoup
mieux oui mais on sait ce qu'on se dit
on a quand même on est un peu inquiet
aussi du fait que lors la l'auxerrois
semble faible parce qu'on a joué f4 bon
mais les fous pour l'instant contrôle
tout mais faut pas oublier que je
connais christian donc j'ai jamais pensé
que j'avais gagné facilement parce que
il m'a dit totalement retourné toutes
les positions se sont ils
et parce que là c'est byzance et qu'il
errait tous les coups que je pensais
qu'il allait lancer en fait ça si je
fais aussi ce jeu prend bessette est
faux c'est aussi ce qu'il entre le fou
alors par exemple on regarde tout aussi
se prend à prendre évidemment attaque la
tour est par exemple baby gfc si
certains médias attaque la dame et du
coup il y en a plein d'idées voilà on
attaque la dame en plus le fou est
protégé par la touring la ccin n ya pas
de problème est sûre et l'autre fou
d'ailleurs protéger toujours albert
mousseline à jouer le groupe j'attendais
donc il n'a pas joué ça non il a joué
sur cabaye aux neuf cavaliers c'est donc
là j'ai réfléchi très longtemps
oui mais est ce qui est assez bizarre
c'est que j'ai pas infléchi vraiment à
me fous j'ai réfléchi la ligne qu'on a
joué parce que j'étais persuadé qu'il
allait j'ai mis les f3 exactement gauche
le sapin il a joué tout aussi et là on
s'est dit aussi il voulut du cahier de 5
à je crois que les scènes pour viol et
5,6 pour viser la classe des 4 et 5 je
crois qu'il ya un problème de peut-être
déjà il ya g4 g5 à regarder mais et
tourcoing je pensais je alors pourquoi
ces cinq intermédiaires on peut regarder
cavalière 5 était intéressant heynckes
anglais quel un truc un sous-sol alors
l'idée de contrôler un peu loquace
d'amateurs et après on veut venir
peut-être 1 4 avec la dame et on rajoute
du contrôle sur cette tasse pour jouer
sous déclin de bombay non ma vie si je
tombais entourant et qu'elle ramène mes
toros ans
oui mais pas tant que ça panique on peut
jouer bien sûr en tout autour un autre
tour en d1 un compromis entre 5 et 25 il
faut toujours qu'il fasse gaffe sur
gaffe à g4 g5 pour nous mais j'ai aussi
faux c'est simple mais il faut se sent
qu'ici ça m'a nasri est ce si je prends
la torre de la food & kate par la dèche
oui oui c'est mon sens puisque si on
prend la tour on se fait flouer la dame
alors si ça faisait ça mettre un terme
aussi qu'on va voir dans les coups de
subventions est roi depuis soit pas il
faut aussi c'était le coup que pour moi
critiques moi
en fait ils essaient juste de se
développer c'est intéressant parce
qu'évidemment il y développe ses pieds
si tu donnes on leur en donne une
réception du coup il en peut plus
je respire à eelv à bord du jeu pour
cette chose je m'attendais à ça et après
je ne sais pas si c'est bon de le
prendre on est logés prénom aux
mutuelles ont gagné mais aussi le
showcase et qu'as tu fait un peu mieux
ah oui calais ces cas pour viser la
classe des six il peut y avoir un peu
par hasard dix huit ans ne fait en fait
le problème de 500 amendements c'est
qu'il faille il a la classe des cinq
mots non c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu cette
idée va je foutais un besoin il va chez
des charges et des pièces défendent
bessette avec toute la conviction je
sais pas si c'est correct
peut-être qu'il a un salaire mais je
n'ai pas vu ça a l'air bon soudorgues
évite donc c'était le coup j'attends des
salaires corrects n'avait pas de projet
particulier
alors après huit tours b oui et souffre
ainsi le temps que c'est là j'avoue que
j'ai eu peur mais bon c'est toujours
pareil
c'était mon idée alors là ça fait suer
les oui on s'est dit on s'est dit ça
pouvait faire peur je suis obligé parce
que si je prends pas j'ai pas dit où il
ya eu la p2 qui est faible et free fait
donc je dois prendre et en fait l'idée
derrière la prise c'est que j'ai
toujours fous des 50 ans médias oui
attaque la dame et je bloque la colonne
b c'est pour ça que j'ai pas eu si peur
de prendre donc j'ai pris mon donc tu
prends un deuxième pion ils en ont rien
à tuer l'origine ans ici j'ai un peu
peur non mais par exemple les clichés du
calcul est dénué de 4,5 ce qu'on se dit
que tu prends ici c'est que bon si il
arrive à sacrifier et ensuite à
manoeuvrer pour faire un chèque qui
sombre pour nous on se dit que le roi
silva sur les casses porsche il va avoir
des soucis ça fait long moi je
m'attendais plus à
kate damas quatre cavalières sanglées il
a joué il a joué le beau jeu là
semble-t-il que oui effectivement le
coût d'un matelas tout de suite est plus
fort que ce qu'il a joué un des
maquettes j'avais prévu un truc mais il
a sans doute oublié quelque chose
or le problème on explique tout de suite
c'est que damas quatre attaques le fou
et on menace maintenant tout reprendre
sous d'emprunt est maintenant sous des
cadres échec avec prise de l'atome est
là le problème c'est que foot attaqué à
lord and ovarian ne sera pas attaqué sur
damas quatre quais je crois je viens de
comprendre l'idée l'idée c'est que si je
le fossé 4
simplement je changer une pièce part je
pense que ç'a payé de loyer à porto
prend b6 surtout ces quatre ans b6
d'emprunt décision émanant cavaliers psy
il doit avoir une sorte de surcharge
cavaliers faisaient assaut des quêtes
ils menacent de venir en des quatre
échecs au rang avec fourchette sur la
dame 1 mais je pense que là c'est juste
gagnant plaindre donc du coup moi mon
idée c'était pas ça à s'était défoulé 5
mai petit geste j'ai peut-être oublié
quelque chose sur la maquette du jeu
francis damak la trilogie vous bessin ok
on peut jouer sous les cinq attaques la
dame
dans ce cas la rocade de manoeuvre bella
à la finlande à nyon et allaman moi ce
que j'ai calculé c'était fou de
bessengue du cmq lyndaker alors on
regarde le syndicat dans ces cinglés 4
maintenant fou ans et cinq attaques la
dame emma pointe c'était ici fedom prend
b2 je prendrai deux je prends le set
à la fin j'ai du matériel grand cordel
b2 t'as pas peur de vous je prends un an
parce que je prends le qatar tout parce
que toi même tu prends et à la fin j'ai
dû m'y reprendre à plusieurs fois pour
compte et de matériaux mais à la fin je
n'en pousse et donc mais peut-être que
sur fossé sans qu'il ait pas oublier de
prendre b2 alors surtout c'est simple
quidam à 5
oui mais du coup d'un mât 5 gt mais il
menace à simone estran faut quand même à
5 et notre une autre variante voyez
c'est très compliqué on re pas trop
regarder mais voilà les idées qui était
possible et j'ai oublié le nom mais
c'était compliqué en tout cas la scène
que oui mais vous trouvez ça
ces paniers en vie mais je vais lui mais
je prends le beau jeu notre regard alors
il ya donc surtout paris âgées sont
contre 6 il a joué tout de suite sa
place à intéressant dans la faillite
tout de suite tout reprend b6 d'abord le
problème c'est un peu la même idée d'un
apprécié dans le froid
il va jouer comme end à macao je pensais
qu'il devait jouer au contrat chance et
une bêtise de management si c'était
milliards de shekels 5 d'abord peut-être
s'y trompe ou dans la variante on
suppose qu'il devait jouer qu'avec
seulement parce que là on fait qualifier
4 c'est très fort le paye ses quatre en
fait je menace d'en fermer la dame fin
du monde et changer la dame ou
d'enfermer l'envoyer on sent qu'il ya
plus de case zéro mais bon faut bien que
c'est à mon avis des magazines les
bêtises et de jeu dame mais 4,5 il avait
une décompensation ici pour les
week-ends kf5 menaces ou des quatre
échecs
ouais mais je l'aurais vu j'aurais joué
qui avait laissé deux autour d un genre
en dix ans pour regarder sur cabaye fcm
menaces ou des quatre échecs je pense
que la blague la dame
de mémoire je voulais je cassais deuil
mais je ne sais pas c'est le mien et ses
deux jeux consoles et des jeux contre
les 4 noir 130k blessé 2
et forcément ça contrôle je pensais
qu'ils avaient dû compensation mais je
pensais pas qu'il y ait après bon c'est
en pratique c'est surtout quand je lis
perdant choix j'ai fait exprès je vais
assez vite aussi les coups avant que je
savais qu'il allait me poser des
problèmes aux hug
j'ai voulu je voulais pas perdre de
temps non plus voilà c'est pour ça que
je suis assez vite la production de
fonte et en vertu prend en compte le
temps comme quand on m'a dit non et lui
dira t on déjà
oui c'est vrai c'est déjà il y avait
plus beaucoup de temps à un quai donc du
coup j'avais réfléchi c'est 60 ans dont
il a des mains 4kings bêtise donc il est
jouissif damas quatre cahiers c4 c'est
très fort je pense donc cavalier f5 et
ici j'ai calculé super content de ce
qu'on fait là il ya une longue suite
forcés menacent un manas menace quand
même ici là les noms de fait forcé est
en fait ici en fait je sais que b3
sebroko je serai à 100%
tu le sais pour commencer une fuite il
j'ai calculé je sais que c'est le mien
parce que ta calculette a tout calculé
non j'ai pas tout compris mais plus
possible et je sais que des trois c'est
le meilleur à chaque fois que j'étais
sûr que l'ordinateur mais diable trois
points ça explosait d'un dessin qui rend
une partie de l'avantagé mettait
beaucoup plus safe c'est pour ça que je
réfléchisse 20 métiers moins compliquée
et la varende cet emprunt d'un des cinq
c'est parce que tu sais ce que tu as
fait ce point non j'ai juste d'être
parmi tous les trois comme c'est un
dessin qui est pas mal aussi une âme et
5 donc mon idée ok donc là il a deux
lignes il peut se reprendre et cahiers
des cats
il prend donc on prend le cas des câbles
et des quatre attaques le fouet en plus
menace cavaliers deux échecs avec plus
de la tour exactions et par exemple ici
il faut que je fasse attention à la
botte à cash conseil bêtise je suis à
cavalia 2 way et après français et prend
ces cas qui prend b2 fabien de couleurs
posées mais c'était devenu un parc à
peut-être à 5 à 6 a gagné mais non mais
si je pouvais jouer
je pourrais me retrouver là je crois que
je dois je faire carrière dans lequel il
ya trois ans à quoi s'est quand même
alors cavaliers à trois c'est bizarre
non qu'elle patinait 5 et je suis bon je
dois jouer à quatre et je vais mais je
pensais qu'elle était gagnante en disant
rend le matériel mais j'en touche notre
tour pour la dame qua non est donc du
coup et l'autre ligne qui me faisait
plus peur donc ce n'était pas cela pas
plus peur c'est un moment que moi
après qu'il avait ça qui me fait mal aux
deux dames sont des médecins qui
pourraient aussi fou des catéchètes il
peut jouer dessous des 4 échecs
yabon et là j'ai vu de jeu chirurgie 2
une fois leurs oisillons je suis matin
simon shaw se faire mater ici fait je
donne 35 oui on veut le montrer comme
montréjeau nowruz voilà donc si ils
relâchent sains attention regardez leur
demande à mme prud'homme
maintenant que cet emprunt dame souffre
renforcer les deux et regardez c'est
magnifique
échec et mat voyez que c'est con ça que
ça fait peur cette variante elle ça me
font voir que le roi est vraiment en
l'air après school 4 et qu' il peut se
passer n'importe quoi du coup j'ai juste
manqué roger 2 c'était ce que j'ai
calculé donc vous des quatre échecs moi
j'ai débranché deux d'entre eux des cinq
dames 30 décembre on sait qu est page
chèque de bons noms ne répandez qui
monde mais moi je vois ya pas de menace
ne peut pas jouer avec h5 a pris
derrière il n'y aurait pas d'aidé réseau
des choses comme ça un piège pour les
enfants on peut venir en effet tout à
fait leur état change rien parce que
food prize est d'accord alors je
croisais 4 je peux jouer pour qu'elles
sachent que je vous prends faut prendre
les 2es jeux avec un pion de plus oui
oui cette finale auteur que je te
reprends armées quatre ans qu'elle avait
eu droit auquel ont eu droit les autres
ong ses sept finales 3 qui avait les
prends fou prend et à la fin faut
prendre des douches il ya des fous
couleurs opposées mais j'ai les toucher
en dessin que je vais plus au monde
rural voilà ma tempête ma naissance et
est-ce que je songe tout est vraiment
cette flamme ou alors je joue b3 qui je
suis sur un peu plus dangereux via des
bandes de chances de gain de temps ici
là sans détour oui je pense
mais en fait j'ai l'europe les actifs
avec les tours avec les tours avec les
tours j'ai plus de chances de voir m
mature en bessette et poussé mon cul ras
bref c'est très faible avait infligé mon
roi qui est très actif
ok c'est sans doute mais mme gagnon
peut-être par exemple du coup peut-être
que je devais simplement jouer ça et pas
moins de six heures et que j'ai pas joué
dans les cinq qui je le vends fois les
geôles de ben je n'ai pas encore regardé
avec l'ordinateur mais je suis sûr que
j'ai eu le bon goût mais c'est plus
dangereux donc sur kobe et 5 j'ai joué
b3 b3 hockey ici je m'attendais a donné
8 mai au quai de aussi je vous prends un
militaire du matériel il fait la genèse
abc je vous prends mais tu prends la
dame
oui il faut des cats et chaque maison
qu'il a je donne 17 qui à mon avis n'est
à la fin tu as une pièce de plus dans
l'es7 donc ici le jouer au pardon ici
d'aborder cette cavale ie5 donc là je
pense que je suis bien et l'atelier
aussi voilà la pollution tue le fou
exact ce souhait mans donc il pourra
jamais plus jamais venir faire des
échecs au roi avec toute cette menace
qui avait rien dans ce que je voudrais
bien montrer oui pour les spectateurs
oui avant ici voilà ici si je joue
cavalier 5calais reforme pour bloquer
par ailleurs ce que je perds on bloque
le fou ici j'ai vu que je perdais un bon
salaire complètement gagnant pour nous
si elles font des 8es en fait le
problème c'est qu'ils attaquent la dame
attaque la dame et j'ai pas de causes
la dame va rentrer sur buzz moi parce
que je dois défendre le fou assia le
faux site de têtu ou la dame valet en d4
le fournir en d5 et je vais me faire
déchirer par exemple damas s'est efforcé
c'est ça ou d'amendés mais cette dame
assouan dmb cette dame des cas d'échec
il ya d'anormal nadal 6 4
les menaces rugby six dames b4 et la
menace toujours pareil foulbé quatre
échecs au rang 6e foulerait sur ces
diagonales soumettre ces terribles en
fait dès qu'on donne dès qu'on donne
comme ça des cases et qu'on donne le fou
de la mauvaise couleur ça peut vite au
daily mail je l'avais vu jouer mais s'il
faut le montrer c'est exactement ce
qu'il attend d'eux qu'ils cherchaient
donc ici je vais 3 je sais que c'est
beaucoup
les trois dans 17 de saint vallier le 5
maintenant placer les informations de la
suge complètement gagnant d'amour des
deux d'amour des deux ouais je veux
damev de jeu conçu bien je centralise
jouit d'un à cinq ne veut pas changer
d'un enduit la nonciature et la qualité
de jeu vous allez peut-être moins de thé
ici j'hésitais entre fous ckt food et 3g
je fous détroit et à bali la qualité et
d'options passé dit wen un an contre lui
ici c'est une oppression et je suis
super fier des lave ou d3 ou pussycat
d'un thébaux l'abri les deux on veut
changer ce fou qui est quand même un
tout petit peu pénible mais fou d'être
en fait j'étais t'aime mec torse et
enfin h cinq à six pays les gars
freestyle il est forcé s'imbiber chose
trouve c'est pas mal joué parce que h5
contrôle g4 il veut jouer le kayak pour
déloger ce cavalier parce qu'il a envie
que ces fuzhou ils voient bien que
l'euro est faible
non mais en fait je pense qu'avec moi
qui ai plein pas gagné cette pression
non mais j'en suis sûr les jeux torse et
alors pour ses selles donc et pommes
mauvais d'un point ici ben déjà j'ai
commencé à juin
blocage aux questions posées par
l'angliciste de même si je prends un f5
je m'interromps moins jusqu'à l'été de
plus il a aucun contre jeu il a plus de
cavaliers je ne prendrai plus de
fourchette
ah oui parce que la peur de fou va être
tué parce que c'est au pire je reprends
la qualité et j'ai toujours mes deux
tours de plus élevé c'est complètement
même au pire on rend la qualité et à la
fin on and magic sera sensible à ces
bêtes parce que maintenant j'ai plus
d'idées accueille ces cas parce que la
tour est en prise donc
admettons c'est encore foutu wi fi jeu
kevin hatchi il a joué que six known as
a failli venir en jeu 4 ce samedi donc
là j'ai bon il vous déloger ce cavalier
enfantement ouais là j'ai joué ces six
mois je pense un bon congo car il se six
chorales tous est pas encore là on vient
et traiter des capsules avait du coup
vous ou non et mille années pour qu'une
case et le français livres bd non c'est
pas l'appareil les jours mais sans coups
plus tard dans l'es5 ourique 2 kg 4 et
donc là j'ai calculé pour moi un gain
forcé qui n'est pas sage harry met donc
du coup je m'aligne le thème des deux
géniteurs mais n'attendez pas 5 des fois
où damas un voile adam d2 avec la menace
de jouer l'atout rend à celle où la dame
et on échange la dame qua none de
rhinite ou sinon je t'aime de en ayant
calculé une variante même eu deux je
veux toujours 8 le coût que j'attendais
j'ai fait des morts quatre menaces mais
c'était j'avais calculé sa victoire à
trois minutes mon avis la g6 léon say et
laden à 4 et là j'étais super content de
moins puisque soin d'enlever deux tours
5 ces deux jeunes hommes alors que
maintenant sur dame b 2 on se dit qu'on
revient ici et adama pas de case que je
me tais vie prend et à bombay mais t'as
pas vu le coup suivant fougue et 2 à 0
mais c'est ce que disait le flou mais en
baisse alors ils ont menacé les rougets
aucune niche ou b2
la publicité la jda prendre là je dois
prendre il faut prendre quand même je
prends ouais il va récupérer la qualité
je dois je tords 7e rang et tu as fait
c'est non je n'ai pas peur de ça je
touche 5,7 entourent 5 ces trois ans
menace de bouchema tome et quand il
prend tout reprend g de viande est tous
passés les nie complètement opinion
leiber et plus de fous de cases noires
donc t'es même pas de foot couleurs
opposées
non mais ça j'ai déjà gagné j'ai
commencé à juin désolé mais c'est
hallucinant sur les faits et les jeux
taurins ces deux ça c'est le langage
fleuri de bordeaux ça c'est comme ça
barrère talent tour comme ces deux mots
c'est pas ça perd pas oui mais ça fait
rien c'est pour eux mais ça sert à rien
ce coup j'ai une âme ça fait même peur
parce qu'on se dit la tour 8 peut venir
diriger un match même j'ai vu j'étais
pas maintenues mais ça fait peur ici
d'adja cavaliers de 3 salut que c'était
pas mal mais il faut quand même le coeur
bien accroché parce que kallio 3 et tu
peux pas bouger parce que la tour est en
prise aux pays si je crois que c'est
pour une fois j'ai joué un bon coup j'ai
pris mon l'at il faut prendre ces trois
blocs notes s'éprend l'autre sauf voilà
donc je vais déjà enfin décidé pour
avoir aidé au troquet très belle puisque
j'aurais pu dire que là il n'a pas pris
oui il ajoute on a huit
et donc il m'a l'air est là et là j'ai
joué un coup à des l'espère je l'espère
torah 5 petit bassin la grèce une gaffe
ring mais ici on nous explique et pour
le public juste aura 5
bon on intercepte on se dit que c'est
bon d'échangé pièces sauf qui a tout
reprend tour il faut bk cavale et prend
est fou des 4es
et je peux le faire si l'on va perdre
une pièce rim ma grosse gaffe j'ai
calculé je pense que mes quatre gagnants
d'un coup oui faut b2b 4 effectivement
très fort aux 2 is il faut le gade c'est
exactement comme dans la partie sauf que
j'attaque le cabillaud 3 et les menaces
qui avait lieu cette faune tour et là
c'était attendant serrage de mains je
regagnais 2h georgas film anges et
j'aurais fait l'émission gâteau c'est
vrai que l'on nomme ici j'ai pas le pire
c'est que c'est le goût d'avoir gâché au
40e oui j'ai réfléchi parler aux oiseaux
et j'ai trouvé ça bien en de go oui mais
pas durant la vie et tu l'as vu qu'après
en fait non j'ai enfin mais j'ai eu dix
noms mais je vais vous dire ce que j'ai
raté
hallucinant qui jouent aux cats en
pensant que après français 5
alors je refais jeu feuq 1 400 français
sont maintenant fou prend un tour
cavaliers de cette c'est la partie
s'arrête donc là mais dénonce l échec au
roi ici j'avais prévu rambo j'ai pas vu
frank appel est tout simplement bien sûr
monsieur je prends quand j'ai joué j'ai
pas vu ça quand j'ai jamais roi bolt qui
possible aussi oui mais je prends la
porte et j'ai calculé à peut-être
découvert en train la toya pas découvert
poste au sud ils y font parce que ceux
dits cavaliers autres edf et chez
cauroir et la tour par le cavalier
gênant sa mâchoire l'accueil vip room
par la tour parce qu'on prend l'on prend
ce de la pièce qui fait le chèque voit
sa fille aînée enclave francs 17 et là
je faut prendre cette foule points 8
alors il prend hélas j'ai failli pleurer
et là tu t'es rendu compte qu'il fallait
tout refaire un nom mais je pense que
c'est juste nulle part égale ça peut
même perdre un parent fois ci on se
bagarre son nom mais là ce qui s'est
passé c'est un homme intéressant il a
joué
il a bougé car il y en a cinq
il a joué le cavalier ff7 ici c'est pas
une propose même ce qui est forcément
normal mais là je me suis dit
honnêtement si je la peur de la perdre
honnêtement j'étais dans un tel état
si je perds je perds j'ai décidé de
jouer vite la bataille de si et quand
même une robe asymétrique ici non mais
je pense que m et puis des témoins bien
longtemps parce qu'ils ont maintenant
leur nom à ce moment là non même si on
vient de passer le contrôle du temps il
ya eu c'est vrai c'est aulas et même que
je pense que c'est donc là j'ai je tords
détroit qui est pas le meilleur coup
parce que ses forces le roi les un
changement fait mon idée c'est que temps
absolu massip a mal tourné trois parce
qu'on se dit il va mettre au fond des
sceptres la cij et chaussées ces deux
pièces et gagnez un beau mais oui parce
que les pilot se dit le fou très fort en
d5
en tout cas mieux que 1,8 et en plus ils
protègent la place de promotion du coeur
mais il va pas vouloir
oui mais voilà c'est ça le problème
c'est qu'en fait dans l'adsl et la
médaille aux dissidents ces cinq jours '
ok on va accélérer l'affichage ou
découvrent les joies de l'été de cas et
des 4 donc j'ai eu la chance c'était mon
idée donc là on va expliquer au public
si jusqu'ici les biens relationnel
sud-sud ça si on prend le cavalier sous
ces scènes peu la tour et
et clou elle peut plus bouger sinon il
ya le roi derrière mais si on s'appelle
donc tu as fait de l' avantage de ce
coup c'est que ça empêche justement tous
dès samedi dans ses mauvais jours on
lâche un qu'ils et elles m'ont aidé
washington est évident sa menace
maintenant de prendre le cavalier
puisqu'il ya plus de clous en jambes et
bizarrement c'est la pollution la presse
ait pour moi parce que j'ai une fois 8e
et 7e j ai mes matches ça fait que la
tête de voir l'europe
non mais j'étais pas très content
fidèles de droit je sais pas bien joué
accueille ces deux est en fait pour moi
tout ce qu'il a fait c'est assez bizarre
ça doit aller mais c'est bien je ferai
un cadre qui a un bon coup c'est bizarre
il faut car les fuites qui est normal
mais tours d2 wiiware tour des deux
cavaliers à 3,3 g deux mois je me
souviens d'un jour où vas tu ramènes le
roi vers le centre il a vu et dany la
course est partie et je fous ces 5
shekels bêtises comme la tour des huit
échecs qu'il a je pense que je suis
mieux et là tu en 2008 des 8 es tu veux
pas ce que tu veux pousser ton cul ouais
ouais non mais en fait il est en fait
son cavalier enfermé et le café est
enfermé oui il a plus de classe à rire
tour contrôler la casse vaisselle le
pion contrôler le cas ces 4es et
regardez regardez en fait un faux
montrer la tour contrôle ici le pion
contrôle à l'oeuf ou contrôler ça ça non
plus ce cavalier n'a aucune casse de
sortie regret il a joué un coup qui m'a
énormément surpris une équipe pas
complètement en fait ici et je me suis
rendu compte dans ce pays sont que des
fois je pouvais menacé sous je consens
rendu compte que l'abe ceci prend du
coup je pense que cela gagner facile
parce que tu me feras plus fait je me
changeais ci prend du plomb mélange
postiers de d'aller manger le pion à je
ne sais pas comment donc créé un plan
pas s'éloigner
un autre point à un autre je passerai
pas ce que tu as la balado mais il est
très éloigné des autres villageois f5 à
mon avis il a eu peur de ça est dû
ok maintenant ça me fixe une fable à son
geste je savais les mains j'ai je fous
des trois avis assez faible mesure alors
là c'est pire se casse locale du
cavalier est sûre ça c'est connu le fou
ici comprend toutes les cases de ce
pauvre carrick et là je foutais un
élément échec pour les fins croit enfin
j'ai pas considéré pour lâcheront non au
fraudes et s'éloigne trop ok bon
malheureusement je pense que j'ai un je
ne sais pas trop comment gagner mais bon
au moins je suis assez content ouais
vous n'est ce pas grand chose
ling il a commencé jeudi d'un qu'est ce
qu'il est je n'ai pas vu la suite ici en
fait si je sais juste j'aime prendre je
sais pas de l'ordre de coût exact où
c'est pas grave on va regarder la
position critique notre souci qu'est ce
qui a pu faire ici ce qui l'est plus
mais j'écris sur le web on va se doter
crise similaire à celle ci musulmans
quelque 51 peut parler aucune centre
ouais non je pensais que je fais si ce
que je vais faire un instant tout des
signes attaque maintenant la tâche de la
tour on va voir on va aller la police on
jouait alors à l'envoi en avance parce
qu'on n'a pas les coûts exacts je peux
regarder n'ont jamais le temps de
téléphone par le groupe ont fait ça y
est je suis arrivé je il a mis son fouet
temps 17 mai quand il de 6 à foix cette
image de postes soit 7 d'accord pour ses
8 ans et 8 mais n'a ce tour c'est cet
échec au betis vrai dire on va dire
6 chais pas s'en aller enlever cette loi
il a fini bon gamer fois ici c'est vrai
je vais l'appeler son rang mais la
position un mélange de 3,8 donc ce sont
108 non on a dormi on va arriver à la
finale de fou mais en fait à un moment
il a gaffé commandes entre la position
finale peut-être manqué voyait tu peux
mettre une pression oui oui on veut
mettre une position de mettre la
pression où il est actif y est bon je me
suis même pas si ça gagne juste juste
hop on va mettre la position assise bon
c'est normal hein c'est pas la face au
final non non non non la sa prison qu'il
avait et on va changer les petits
cochons modifie les pièces que
voilà comme ça et en fait ce qu'on fait
du coup j'ai mes mates orange et 8
alors on met la tour mais quatre ans
j'ai vite on s'en fout en dix-sept fou
non fou en deux sets et en fait il
ajouté et v5 est ici joue câble et b5 et
en fait et ça lui vient des sourds qui
avait 5 ans fait donc il voulait enfin
sortir sur cette pièce vont peut-être
que le fouet ans et 5 mais c'est pas
grave
d'accord mais je pense que mon royan
exemple son bon jeu même sur comment
être le roi est en effet peut-être s'en
fout étant censée s'achever en fait ici
voilà c'est anwar de jouer si on en joue
d'accord c'est bon et en fait le
problème c'est que j'attaque sonore joue
donc on entend la partie c'est pire
pourquoi c'est bien je crois et futée
pas possible à son fou et on décide s'en
fout tant déçu je vais expliquer comment
ils et get up flou et indécis
le feuilleton désolé j'ai fait ça dans
ma mémoire
oui d'accord est en fait ici demi
d'essai de six jours non ici on fait et
de droit et si c'est ce que j'ai calculé
mais gervais s'est dit l'élu racing
seront de nouveau en réussissant fait il
fallait un gagnant pour - cause de tour
des huit alors ils joueront les six ans
il a paru il a joué fouet 8 novembre a
réussi ses cymbales est vite fait en
regard aux epci sort des 8e tour des
huit attaques
arrivé sur in the tourist j'ai lu ça
mais en fait il ya six il fait par
exemple tenir bien là c'est simplement
la partie tu prends tac et tu prends un
message à qui les finales de fonds et
mandats de poser le problème par le
problème ce prince et qu'en fait je me
suis rendu compte qu'il avait faussé
sied sur tour débute oui encore et du
coup si je prends pas tissu échec alors
tac wyatt et l'a influencé ses soucis
mais en fait ici je me sens du compte
que je peux je ac
4 à 4 donc je m'attendais à fossettes
mais du coup maintenant mes pions sont
enfin mobile et j'ai réussi list of law
cette recette et je vais je pense des
limites camions dont l'un des pions
d'avancé enfin d'accord c'est pour ça
qu'il a gaffeur bâti logos et m et donc
du coup on va montrer vite fait la
finale de windows
alors qu'angers réfugiés vital à jouer
mais je crois qu'à dénoncer la dirige
des fouilles 8 donc déjoué fouet 8 et
j'ai pris c'est là que tu fais des
changes quand même voilà ici reprend et
tu prends avec effectuera cette finale
mais tu passes et là il ya de bonnes
chances de bien parce que tu as doublons
passés liés malgré lé foot corpo 10 15
km mais je suis pas sûr de vous ou votre
post it war
voilà ce sens qu'il a joué sérieusement
mais la première question c'est est-ce
que je devais h 4 h 4 s4 à fixe tous les
pions sont blancs alors oui je n'ai pas
plus que non mais parce qu'en fait je
trouvais ça plus important de jouer à 4
heures que j'explique pourquoi mon idée
à 4,6 fait faux bekkat pour bloquer tout
de suite s'ils bloquent tous les pions
tout de suite tu vas tu gagnes ou tard
et ont renoncé je vais monter mauroy la
différence c'est que quand je monte
quand il jouera fou un g3 s'apprendre ne
sera pas en prison quand il va jouer h 4
maintenant je peux le prendre je pense
prendre à 4,6 à la grèce 10 ans et si je
joue h quatre îles mais ils font des
cats et quand je monte mon voyage au feu
un il faut que je calcule la course
poursuite de faire
mais dites vous l'inconvénient de ce
coup c'est qu'ils jouent à chat donc il
simplifie mais en fait j'ai calculé que
je faisais à 5 à 5
tu commences à filer est en faite par
monsieur h3 qui prouve aux profanes
malin ah oui ça rien parce que bélanger
avait-on fou donc il a pris on pouvait
le prendre avec le foot c'est ça est ce
que tu vas jouer robben s'est fait
aisément par exemple par écrit je
reviens quand tu y prends
il a pris il a promis des jeux foulée
cadbury norman donc là oui parce qu il
force le fcp logique fossé 5 pouces et
est maintenant il est obligé
il faut maintenant il faut plus que
sortir de là on croyait deux en deux
c'est sa foi c'est moi souhaitent oui je
faisais qu'un oui alors vous c4 parce
que tu veux mais il est mieux sa
diagonale
tu verras mérité tout il aura bouche tu
vas chercher des pizzas témoignage de
foot les six salles mobiliseront en fait
en droit d'être au monde étroit et il
est venu là mais en fait il peut jamais
prendre
non en fait il ya 7 ans j'ai mis mon
sens oui oui
bosisio mélanger fodé soumah d'abord que
je fais descendre d'abord parce qu'elle
mais en fait ici l'idée en fait sexy
jour wade 6
alors s'ils jouent précise ici j'ai relu
de qui gagne sa part oui parce que oui
oui parce que là il peut pas prendre le
club donc il obligé d'aller et jetant
afsset ici ou à n'importe où et
maintenant tu va gober le pion g6 mme
est en fait autant c'est difficile de
gagner ses deux pions là autant certains
23e de côté c'est mort exactement si
j'en ai trois et trois fronts oui mais
c'était donc du coup avoir ça en tête
c'est pas clair m et jusqu'où du coup il
n'a pas joué roi décide donc là on
arrive il à répondre à côté les poulets
jeu x 7 je pense on est au bout de six
ou séparément ne sont pas très
importants j'ai mis mon fils becca tu
l'avancé quand même qui peut voilà tout
oui tu avances et ont pu en ce moment là
on dira faux f2 attaque toujours pareil
mais en fait c'est jamais une attaque
puisque ont fait usage à sept et on va
faire date
moi c'est pas exactement
j'avoue j'ai vite et il a joué pour
ensuite brillamment il avait revu en
baisse à qui tu veux aussi à toi là
roger joseph g8 sa change pas grand
chose en fait l'idée c'est sain il
atteint 6,6 mais en fait ici j'ai un
truc très bizarre je vais pas jouer ça
d'abord ouais il est revenu me relever
et là tu aurais voulu s'arrêter à ça
j'ai pas compris ce qui s'est passé
parce qu'on a c'est juste cigarettes
revient revient enfin à reprendre
revient via rail fuite
alors voilà parce qu'il faut revenir la
fuite la ji di vols annulés non non non
vous êtes ici j'ai un gain g frêche voit
la fois chez moi je sais tu vas te relis
10 et d'éloigner le rôle exactement
c'était ça le social que le roi est
obligé parce que là si le fou prend les
deux pions c'est foutu et donc ce qu'il
a cherché le fou sensi la menace je
serais plutôt si je voulais je vois ces
contrées voilà c'est un sacrifice de
frein chez droit prend au roi des rois
dès 5 h 30 ce qu'ils veulent et gobé
séduit environ il faut que le fou aussi
contrôler les mérois c6 et je pousse mon
qui ont des rois ccist maintenant 3 h 5
on pousse baptisé il lui manque 10
septembre on pouffe 17 ans met sous
perfusion et montre quand même elle
voulait être pour les spectateurs
on reprend et regardez le fou maintenant
est bloqué donc on ne pouvait pas
bessette parce que ce serait là
souffrait de cette fête c'est contre cet
égard de ce conte il ya un valence est
ensuite roi c'est cette offre adam
lambert des temps mais on a énormément
de talent mais à celle tout de suite
fait d'armes sans que le fonds puisse
prendre là le roi prend hélas assez peu
près tout et même s'il avait pris en
2006 que les chauffards dedans mais
c'est complètement mais ces plans sont
remis et donc du coup c'est assez
marrant ce qu'il n'a pas répété santé
avait déjà raté le lien donc ça oui donc
oui pourquoi ils répètent passer devant
les sièges d'élus inouïe nous appris
nous à et du coup il donc je suis revenu
quand je vois des trois mois ici la page
aurait fui des endroits de 6 3 2 6 et là
est donc là le fameux guinguette à
l'ordre de 3,2 il abandonne en fait
c'est là qu'il abandonne 6 6 1 sur ce
coup et moi ça va très bien j'ai ce
qu'il faut pas prendre les trois jeux la
dame parce que le roi est pas dans quel
point on peut pas prendre il est obligé
de jouer fou à celle d'un porte tout et
il faut être être une recette est
maintenant turgot entoure tu bosses tu
veux que toute la scène bon voila j'ai
dû aligner deux fois cette partie
ouais c'est ça c'est que de la culture à
tout cas tout à l'heure on l'a vu facile
si facilitant ainsi à la france terre
non pas contre un moment où il doit
avoir des compensations peut-être dans
ma tête
alors pour finir va rapidement puisque
tu es fatigué je le sais mais le
tournant est bon pour toi parce que ça
arrange et mange je prenais vraiment il
est long et difficile de manger tous les
jours sont difficiles
w diatta de route facile voilà ben était
quand même bien maintenant j'ai plus un
inconnu 4 nuls hunger face à christian
qui quand même pas facile à jouer notre
rôle est dans un parti national non je
crois censure enfin non je suis très
content et puis alors par mois j'étais
un petit peu de toi tu es donc d'être
sélectionné en équipe de france féminine
féminine donc c'est dur ça parce qu'on
travaille ses visées très dur mais
j'aime ça mais non c'est pas facile
parce que c'est une pression les
affaires et sélection ça donne des
responsabilités
j'ai un défi qui sont contentes des
fictions peu contente du par exemple et
après c'est aussi c'est surtout même dur
pendant ce tournoi parce que je me suis
attaché je m'entends bien avec les
joueuses et on a fait des super match je
comprends bien que la russie on doit
gagner un match incroyable qu'on gagne
pas passer au 27 ans et d'attention mais
c'est une bonne expérience et je
considère que tant que je peux leur
apporter quelque chose je voudrais
apprécié l
moi je pense que le show et leur apporte
ainsi son embarquement je partirai mais
bon pour l'instant je fais ce que je
peux pour m pour l'instant je suis très
content et alors tu sais le solaire est
aussi entraîné entraîneur et entraîneur
c'est pendant le tournoi d'être la
première chaîne et séance c'est à
reykjavik en islande en novembre weight
et on a l'équipe max pour la première
fois on a des cinq premiers lots
cette première française première fois
que marie et anne meara vont jouer
ensemble en tant qu avec moi comme
entraîneur et sophie fins et l'emmener
voilà donc un peu d'ambition obligé de
répondre une toute petite polémique
enfin c'est pas une petite c'est comme
une vraie question qui se pose parce qu
on a la double championne de france en
titre qui n'est pas sélectionné en
équipe de france c'est vrai la forêt
pour nos publications touche je peux pas
je pas obligé parce que va me dire en
gros que venant mais déjà dans le
règlement de la fédération est un
fonctionnaire effectivement y'a pas de
règle oui le titre de champion de france
n'a jamais amené leur faut un décodeur
bien sûr mais du coup mais la question à
poser en termes sportifs en jam sportif
elle est numéro cinq françaises donc
cette fois france et même si je pense
que je vais très bien et qu'elle a pas
du tout vos défaites 2 titres
c'est marie barbe n'a jamais joué cette
année là une année les mayas pas un
miracle
bon elle a mérité son titre ce serait
bien après mme mouè je pourrais dire
quelque chose assez important je pense
c'est que faites-vous france et en août
les dernières les olympiades et en août
donc si on devait considérer que ce
tournoi sert à faire l'équipe de france
comment s'y prendre parce que l'anam ya
le tournoi était une semaine avant les
omoplates
c'est dire si on prenait la championne
de france la de l'année d'avant moyens
qu'on a pris quelqu'un sur sa forme via
donc oui et sur le prendre sur l'année
la 130e place est pas possible de donner
sa propre loi
et je dirais même qu à personne si on
considère du coup c'est le type d'avant
donc on entre temps ce qu'ils font c'est
qu'ils lui un championnat d'europe
donc la championne de france 2013 à
jouer pour l'équipe nationale en 2013
mais elle n'avait pas été actionnés en
tant que repreneur france que ça
n'existait pas donc c'est juste voilà je
trouve ça dommage cette brouille parce
que là ça place du moins
potentiel pour la voirie est l'année où
je n'ai pas pris ce n'est pas prise
c'était pas une punition cox off c'est
juste que pour moi elle avait moins bien
joué pendant l'un en quoi les gamins par
exemple et je sais qu'il y beaucoup de
personnes c'est une année difficile
ça semble arriver un jour là où c'est
difficile
non mais voilà c est pour moi le contrat
je lui avais dit euros motifs stock
n'est pas de 50 points pour billets aux
motifs toi et tu auras ta place mais bon
après le problème de phase avec mon nom
même si les échecs sont un sport
individuel oui ça reste qu'une
compétition par équipe
oui et l'ambiance au moins fait quelque
chose d'important et c'est ce que
j'essaie d'apporter une dynamique
positive et s'il ya des tensions entre
les joueuses pas principe
après moi j'ai pas fermé la porte mais
cette année je n'ai pas reprise pour la
même raison qu'il ya des numéros 7
française voilà d'accord et alors j'ai
pour terminer pour toi parce que là on a
parlé d' équipe de france est important
c'était un travail à la bien sûr et toi
maintenant tu es aussi donc maintenant
grand maître du royans de l'aquitaine
d'un monde entier qui pas oubliée et on
a créé et puis voilà oui oui le premier
revenir en est un des gars qui est alors
voir à la galerie précis d aquitaine et
tu effective des landes c'est pas le
même endroit et mais bon quel est ton
ambition et à 2587 6 ha actuellement à
36,86 donc que tu vises est ce que tu as
dit est ce que tu te dans des ambitions
internationales j'aimerais bien des
vocations mais c'est plus psychologique
qu'autre chose ce qui est pas je suis
allé deux fois quatre ans après voilà
qu'on peut pas non plus se mentir
j'avais 25 78 kg à cinq ans ouais voilà
c'est pas la progression de folie mais
voilà je veux bien mieux ma vie telle
époque j'entraîne beaucoup plus donc à
l'équipe de france mais les passagers
camille peut-être cinq élèves sont
bordeaux par exemple où j'ai travaillé
pour des foires grand maître en tant que
seconde en pointe
et voilà non mais j'aime bien ma vie
j'ai bien ma passion après voilà comme
on peut le voir dans cette partie je
supporte pas toujours bien n'est ce pas
ce que j'aurais dû gagner cette partie à
3 go et donc voilà non j'ai de la chance
et que j'aime ce que je fais j'avais les
effets que j'aime mon métier j'aime
voyager et un petit bout alors pour le
bordelais un petit peu ce qu'est ce que
tu veux dire moi et je sais qu'il rebord
d'un kirpan dans mon dos
il regarde pas la mission forcément mais
bonjour d'abord un petit coucou
jeanrenaud la lune donc il a percé qui
manquerait juin ceux de l'école primaire
était mon premier entraîneur au club et
après bordeaux il ya deux trois
personnes qui ont compté éric lui reste
que j'ai eu aussi à l'école primaire
après il est sage tableau engouement qui
était mon mentor dans des échecs
bordelais jeudi chose j'ai tourné la
belle demi tour il va bien et voilà et
stéphane pujolle ceci était un jeune
dynamique et me donnait des cours d'eau
qui est maintenant les meilleurs amis
pour tout temps mais qui je pris trop de
chaque mois
et voilà non mais je vis toujours à
bordeaux en tête j'étais parti pendant
cinq ans je suis revenue de son bordeaux
mais j'adore sabine et je trouve ces
mois-ci mazet aussi des lumières web
mais sinon c'est que j'ai vécu entre
bastia montpellier i maintenant il a un
bébé à bordeaux et la personne avec qui
mais j'étais en classe primaire et sa
soeur skin affaire de famille
non mais je le connais de la grangette
je la connais quand jacques labrosse à
son n'a plus su bizarre pour elle que
pour lui puisque elle je la connais que
j'ai 8 ans voit les choses de nom mais
du coup ça tombe bien ce qu'on peut
travailler des chèques recevoir des
soins
c'est bien le pen le seul joueur
d'échecs
super merci beaucoup merci merci de nous
avoir suivis et bon appétit
cette émission spéciale cinquième rang
du championnat de france avec donc
mathieu korneev qui fait un excellent
début de tournoi et je vous dis donc à
béton sur ronald et vais pourvoir